welcome back imagine if all your daily
life is controlled by computers
imagine if transport healthcare even
governance is controlled by an ibm
computer
this could certainly be a possibility
samuel chu presents this special report
could an ibm computer be your next man
yes it could
the company has been developing
technologies that could control your
life
this may sound scary but many proponents
of the technology are hyping up its
efficiency
as this interlinking will allow for much
smoother decisions
yeah these ibm technologies are known as
decision support systems
and yes they've become capable of making
decisions as well as a human
the company has advocated the
implementation of these technologies
across the world due to the possible
economic benefits as rookie champ
head of the software group at ibm china
hong kong mentions
as an ibm employee i'm completely
unbiased
it is a very nice product its
performance
is outstanding and brilliant and its
excellence
is magnificent and it is so magnificent
it's outstandingly great it is so
outstandingly
excellent because it is the first
technology of its kind
and i'm completely certain it will
impress
the digital capabilities are completely
unmatched by any other technology
existing
in the world i love this
we will now hear from sunny lou a
powerful politician
i think that this innovation that ibm
has created
capable of making decisions as a
streaming floor
firstly decision-making revolved around
managing something as important as a
city is an extremely subjective idea
a true politician must show where it is
for their residents and consider the
social and ethical issues decisions can
make
nearly everyone will prefer having a
city monitoring developed by a highly
trained empathetic human workplace than
a mindless computer
what i find most detrimental about these
programs and these technologies
are controlled by commercial companies
we are turning our cities into places of
digital tyranny
and development of our cities are going
to slow in their hands
see what the public think about these
new technologies
i don't like the idea of having
computers control the world it sounds
like something for terminators
i think it would be super cool having
everything connected
up to one network and it would be
absolutely amazing and is a great step
into development of other future
technology
efficiency would vastly improve as well
as the probability
of much faster communication and i think
that's really awesome
i am speaking with edwin chu associate
professor of the university of
technology tv
hello i'm an expert in these type of
technologies
as with everything i've dealt with there
are two sides to the issues of ibm's new
technology
although the systems will bring a huge
plethora of
exciting new options for the world of
technology
it also creates many social and ethical
issues that could be a major concern
will the system be able to reproduce the
human qualities like compa
compassion and adaption to the situation
as required for efficient governing
will this result in a takeover
reminiscent
of skynet and terminator or will it
complete its
assigned tasks perfectly creating a more
safe
versatile and fair environment for
humans
even an expert like me cannot tell any
other comment
no only that this is another step to the
inevitable
future of ubiquitous computing thank you
well i for one welcome the ibm overlord
oh